[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see I loved when he dumped me
you know I say that proudly I'm gonna
grab no I don't shout me if it aint
great car a be equal to whack you're
like Howie and this is more damn grass
dog walk well you know about that dogs
are one mouth to feed
so I come to bills every time I eat
something you see a bunch of nice state
robot be contempor beef my bros ten
years leave your uncle science but we go
chemistry
I ain't that same kid way back when it
was lost whiteboards felt-tip pens
English plus it was my sentiment nah man
saying free my guy doing ten life change
y'all quick just slide web are y'all
gonna get hello that reads all for life
in those I'm exclusive I'm a busy fella
must be on good terms with her man she
felt my form in a week or so it's been
sauce by the clan restore the nuances
officer we don't know how to see if I
press gas that's work to do run disturb
in London even if I'm injured with two
crutches Doris to outrun them see there
ain't no comparison if I stay consist in
your favorite rapper who imitate
Medellin 60s get yes that gentleman and
the Jose I'll be managing wah I don't
say boss no more ring like Dumbledore
low times used to go Hawks on the score
laughing sweet still thanking the Lord
still thanking the Lord I'll put the
essence standard flight stands there
drip easy of course when I don't do
repeats or pulls
I've been mileage like a bunch for if I
get one that I want to enforce if it
feel nice time I get some more standard
I'm on wrong so I shall kill for the
brand and close your madness don't think
you know me this music things 1:8 for
the fresh I love this [ __ ] control the
fees that I wished you gonna finish the
issue I pretty made a hundred bands from
the magician team I believe me the onion
plants a blow for everyone pie the issue
mom said daddy need pans for any fans
from a cache miss you
was in love with a magical time meeting
battle me come on kiss you rose in the
cockpit
but when a man lines my a tobacconist oh
man we look awesome and they ain't what
one nickel month
I couldn't all well and uni but I just
knew that a life rent man I'm paying
that back his mud agree well fees and
shanks of our Peter good that I make it
back I don't do things who taps if I
take a loss on my ticket back to make
him Rex talk to me about breaking
patched as I able to strangest catching
up real man
God let another man per your munch and I
find where he lives it's gonna get less
about designer kicks as I earring my
slightest [ __ ] and I say I win because
I've already lost my license this and I
know my mommy don't like this [ __ ]
robber I can to get out of it [ __ ]
store water let out an innocent
[Music]
[Music]